okay there's a very tense situation
developing in Venezuela which I have to
cover which I've been looking forward to
covering and which a lot of people are
going to be extraordinarily angry with
me for covering in the way that I'm
about to cover it but that's okay I do
the stories the way I see them period
full stop nothing else needs to be added
to that okay this relates to Venezuelan
president Nicolas Maduro and a guy named
Juan Guido the headline from the last 24
hours is that Venezuelan opposition
leader and president of the National
Assembly Quan Gua though has declared
himself interim president of Venezuela
after rejecting the election results in
a coalition with some other Venezuelan
political higher-ups which saw Nicolas
Maduro reelected strongman authoritarian
Venezuelan president Nicolas Maduro was
recently re-elected but was reelected
after effectively rigging the election
and so why though claims that according
to the Constitution he can be appointed
interim president until there are new
elections which will presumably be more
fair or would ideally be more fair at
some point in the future and the idea is
that this interim president is supposed
to oversee the creation of a
transitional legislative body to
organize and run those eventual fair
elections what do we know about the
recent quote reelection of Nicolas
Maduro well we know that in the midst of
riots and economic collapse Maduro Rose
approval rating was in the toilet so
what he did was to start efforts to
maintain control over the country that
included repressing a movement to have a
recall election which was cancelled
despite 70% approval for that recall
eventually though Maduro was up for
reelection anyway and that's what we
eventually got we got that that election
Maduro won by cheating he banned
opponents from running against him with
various charges he moved polling
stations around in areas where he had
significant opposition that's a tactic
that should remind us all of what
Republicans try to do in the United
states with voter suppression he started
to imply that people who don't vote for
him might lose their rations which in a
country that has so much hunger not
enough money not enough supplies and
basic provisions for food that's a major
threat to be making either implicitly or
explicitly and he ended up after all of
this with quote 68% of the vote which is
very difficult for anybody who's even
remotely informed to believe it wasn't
just the Opposition in Venezuela that
questioned the results the European
Union rejected the election the United
Nations rejected the election numerous
American allies around the world
rejected to recognize this as a
legitimate election and the United
States has now recognized why though as
a legitimate interim president
argentinian right-wing president Macri
has also done the same and in
retaliation Maduro has officially cut
off ties with the United States
Venezuela is going to kick out American
diplomats they're going to try to
continue the authoritarian rule and
that's where we get to the analysis of
the situation here's the the problem
that we're going it that I'm going to
have with part of the left in the United
States there's this call it what you
want I sometimes call it the Leninist
left the Leninist left likes to act like
Maduro is the progressive when in
reality he has progressive sounding
populist rhetoric but his tactics and
his rule is exactly that of
authoritarians in different parts of the
world and in many ways overlaps with
American Republican authoritarian ideas
there are geopolitical reasons and
so-called communists fear which tell us
a lot about why people like Trump and
Mochrie oppose Nicolas Maduro but when
you actually sit down for a second and
say okay let me ignore whether Iran or
McCrone or Trump or Maquis support or
oppose Maduro let's look at what he does
let's examine the populist rhetoric that
is actually a guy's veiling it's it's
thinly veiled authoritarian strongman
policy voter suppression almost
identical in men
ways to what Republicans do antipathy
towards the media and courts that is so
reminiscent of Donald Trump although he
goes much further election results that
are about as believable as Kim jong-un
got a hundred percent of the vote and
thinking of that as a representation of
the North Korean perspective on Kim
jong-un or Putin received whatever
percent of the vote it was that he
supposedly received and case in point
start to take a look at who
congratulated Maduro on his win lots of
Donald Trump's authoritarian crushes as
we like to call them China North Korea
Russia Syria Turkey this is where Trump
has been sort of smitten right Trump
smitten with the Chinese President for
making it possible to be president
indefinitely if he continues to be
reelected Kim jong-un is sense of humor
and he's such a smart guy Putin what do
I even have to say about Putin tacitly
Bashar al Assad impressed with some of
president Erdogan's authoritarian
actions that's the list of people who
are supportive of the wind by Nicolas
Maduro so you might be saying hold on
David that's sort of ad hominem saying
that we either should be for or against
Maduro based on who else is for or
against him know know what I'm telling
you is the opposite if you are skeptical
of opposition to Maduro because Trump
says that he supports the interim
president then how can you
simultaneously apply that ad hominem
logic when I mention all of the other
authoritarians around the world who are
defending Nicolas Maduro either we are
going to evaluate Nicolas Maduro on the
facts on his actions or we are going to
take into consideration all world
leaders who both favor or oppose him you
can't have it both ways
we were already seeing the Leninist left
frame this as a right-wing US backed
astroturf forced regime change and
they'll point to the fact that Trump is
supportive of the interim president but
at a certain point we've got to
distinguish the logic from the ad
hominem right I mean Hitler like dogs
and I like dogs
what does that actually tell us about
any particular policy or other world
leader on which we might have opinions
you know Kim jong-un breathes air and
other humans breathe air to say that
there's any way to take that and analyze
policy doesn't make sense and I think we
need to apply the same critical thinking
here I am a progressive I'm against
strongman dictators I'm against people
who subjugate the basic institutions of
democracy so I'm opposed to Nicolas
Maduro period as far as what will happen
next
it may end up coming down to where the
Venezuelan military falls on this
because in these situations the person
with the support of the military often
ends up winning the political battle and
right now there's every indication that
the military is mostly behind Nicolas
Maduro including on the basis of a
speech that top military officials gave
this morning flanked by huge pictures of
Hugo Chavez and Nicolas Maduro that
could change but if the military remains
united behind Maduro he will likely be
able to retain power you should expect
massive repression of protesters by the
military including violence including
tear gas and rubber bullets they're not
going to allow it anymore than they
absolutely have to or can't control and
I was speaking actually this morning to
some Venezuelan refugees I think is the
right term who are living in my home
country of Argentina which by the way is
no paradise right now okay no shortage
of massive massive economic problems in
Argentina but at least it's not what's
taking place in Venezuela they believe
it is going to get very very ugly and
even though they were hoping to return
to their home country of Venezuela
sooner than later it is that they are
realizing that they probably have to
settle in for quite some time in
Argentina because it is going to in all
likelihood get very ugly for a pretty
long period of time in Venezuela send me
your thoughts about the situation there
i'm on instagram at david pakman the
show is on instagram at david pakman
show after
break I will interview Francois Margolin
who has a very interesting new
documentary where he interviews
jihadists in Mali he joins me after the
break one of today's sponsors is privacy
calm / Pakman this is a free service
that I've actually been using myself for
a while now and I love it you just take
a few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below